[Music]
in rogue you're an undercover detective
yes and you were very serious about
learning martial arts for this not just
uh you know any old man not not what's
martial art specifically did you learn
well i wanted something because i'm an
undercover cop i didn't want to look too
you know too technically uh aware and i
wanted something that was much more
street so my wonderful trainer in london
came up with krav maga which is an
israeli close combat system very sort of
dirty street fighting and apparently i
have lethal elbows really yeah when you
say it's dirty street fighting i don't
know what you mean exactly just
well you'll use whatever you you have at
your disposal you know rather than
play you'll play dirty you'll do
whatever it takes you'll gouge the eyes
you'll go into the ghoulies you'll pick
up whatever you've got i mean i could i
could really achieve quite a lot with
just a few things
that we have i'm sorry you you you call
them the ghoulies
is that what you uh you know exactly
what i'm talking about no i know what
you're
i know what you're talking about i just
i don't i have not heard that have you
heard that expression i've not heard
that expression i know what she means no
i know
it's almost onomatopoeia isn't it
ghoulies
no no no i've never heard that and i've
watched plenty of zombies
kind of a cockney oh get him in the
ghost please
yeah that's not in mary poppins i've
watched that movie 15 times
at no point does mary poppins hit
someone in the ghoulies with an umbrella
but if she did yeah then she'd be you
know yeah very well protected so those
are and that you use your elbows to get
those areas into the eyeballs apparently
i have i have lethal elbows yeah yeah
which i actually feel much more
confident these days
my elbows do you think you could use it
in a real situation do you think you
know not that you want to but if you
think if you think that you could how
many moves to take a guy down
well two
eyes and ghoulies
or
one ghoulie other ghoulie yeah there's
two ghoulies
[Laughter]
wow okay
it's like
very nice i will not fight you you
frighten me now